[Music]
so you guys know that uh machine gun
kelly and megan fox are now engaged yes
yes you also know your gun for that one
to celebrate that they have started a
blood drinking ritual are they drinking
their own blood or i heard about it it's
like a little bit of a couple drops or
something a couple drops of blood but
we're like vampires like saying guys do
not do this [ __ ] that's exactly what's
going on oh really
vampire organizations not not community
vampire organizations they gotta drink
other people's what do they do like
multiple animations no there's a there's
a new orleans vampire association
newport new orleans yes and the
co-founder's name
please don't laugh
it's like remy or something it's it's
balfazar ashtanison i was wrong
and are they trying to pretend that
they're transylvanian or something yeah
that's a good vampire name it can't be
like named todd no you can't be toxic
you can't be taught you can't be peanut
but you can't be peter the vampire you
can't be yeah so um
they say precautions have to be take
before you drink your lover's blood
um though being in a monogamous
relationship obviously helps alleviate
risk but there is potential for disease
and blood-borne illness really
mm-hmm it took him a vampire to
something they're acting like they
[ __ ] drank a whole bottle of blood
like this and just like [ __ ] pounding
it how much blood are they drinking just
a couple droplets but technically yeah a
couple drops could have some stuff in it
what's the point of them drinking each
other's blood it's like i love you
doesn't that happen all the time in the
mma can't they just 69.
no it's the semen
just go down on your your girl when
she's on a period that's that's done
that's it yeah it's normal i totally
forgot about that but we need to like
service her as well you know then you
cut your penis and you put in her mouth
oh
cut your penis
oh jesus yeah that way you she bleeds in
you you bleed in her you know i'd rather
just take the bloodborne
illness let me make a note real quick to
add that that's we're going to cut that
for reals yeah yeah that's a good clip
bart's saying cut your dick off and put
it in your mouth no you just do a little
quick slice of roux you're trying to be
a wine funnel it's like a little
you could get your circumcision done the
same day
oh yeah does that make your stomach turn
yeah i think that's how guys should get
circumcised
because you let her you cut it off and
put it in someone's mouth as a baby i'm
physically uncomfortable as an adult
this is why you guys are best friends
this is why you keep churning over like
your friends and on this show because
that's exactly what it is you know why
because you alienate people
hey low blow man low blow it's how you
get the blood out like low cut you know
yeah burning bridges cutting down i
wouldn't voice these things but like
let's say if my my significant other was
like oh you want to drink a little bit
of blood come memory oh my god let's do
it that's that's your talk let's go to
the [ __ ] restaurant and get some pigs
blood baby yeah whose idea do you think
this was was it mgk or had to be megan
fox because you you'd do anything for
that wouldn't you
first of all if you're with megan fox
don't you wake up every day and just go
all right whatever the [ __ ] you want you
wanna [ __ ] my [ __ ] head
[Laughter]
first thing in the morning every morning
you just wake up with a [ __ ] log of
dookie
well you wake up to the warmth and
you're like oh god damn because my
head's getting [ __ ] on him
i love her
when it's megan fox's [ __ ] you just keep
your eyes closed i'm almost there and
like yeah all right
does that does that uh translate to you
guys where the um how hot a woman is
you're willing to do grosser [ __ ] yep of
course
grosser is not the word it's just more
like anything yep i think there's a
limit though that's the part of the
equation
what's the limit for you huh not
cheating on the head i'm okay with that
i'm that was shitty you're okay with
having [ __ ] on your head come on dude oh
come on bro look at me bro that's why
he's wearing hat today first of all if
you ever have a kid like this man you're
going to get [ __ ] on your head
that's true it's going to happen you get
[ __ ] everywhere so what's the big deal
that's awesome sexual passion [ __ ] seems
a little different than your child's
diaper this is going to be a different
dog shit's much bigger don't judge dude
don't judge me
maybe i'm being judgmental you're being
judgmental but can you imagine megan fox
making eyes at you while she's [ __ ]
drinking milk shaking you know you gotta
take a [ __ ] pound of [ __ ] on your
head well she's downing in horchata
she's like this one's for later babe and
it's like horchata at a time a
chomperado same time
that's a good combo and she gives you
that knowing look and you're like
this one's going to be diarrhea i'll do
it i'll just split my hair down the
middle just so i could take it real good
and give her a little gutter
and then and then she's like oh i wonder
where the toilet is you're like it's
right here
i'll get the toilet right here
sweetheart i'll get the toilet seat and
i just put it on right here i'm gonna
sit on down later you put the wax paper
on it was your whole head gonna go in
her ass while he's [ __ ] put this is
where her butt cheeks go she's like oh
huh how do i flush you like
pull my ear
you gotta make the noise you know what i
mean
anyway what's this one about
nigel what do you think what's your take
on this guy i won't let anybody [ __ ] on
my head you megan don't watch no okay
you're in l.a a hot woman everywhere you
know but not megan fox hot woman there's
a lot of megan foxes here though do you
think she's overrated because she's not
just a hot woman she's a hot woman that
comes with their own bank account that's
different she wasn't transformers dude
make your own money so you don't have to
let people [ __ ] on your head
i never never watched like two girls one
cup and thought that looks like fun
right that's not fun yeah that's why
everyone's passing around because
everyone's like oh this is sexy
[Laughter]
the original allure oh that's kind of
kinky
like and then and then every time guys
get caught like oh isn't this [ __ ]
crazy i wasn't jerking off to this [ __ ]
it was [ __ ] crazy
that's why it got viral yeah jerk it
smacked my balls i've never seen it and
then you google it all the links are
purple you know
yeah
everything's already been clicked on
yeah that's the first vr porn i'm
loading be the cup
like browsers back then didn't have
incognito mode right so everything
people just saw everything you've seen
before the purple link including the
viruses and the new programs that are
stuck in the park
i don't know how that ended up there you
know why is it like 14 toolbars in
internet explorer you know
you have to love being a guy though and
thinking that because you have a vpn and
incognito mode
nobody ever will know
nobody knows it works it's worked for
decades it works for your mental health
maybe but yeah i think that's the
purpose of mental health is really it's
a mental health support it's good that's
good yeah that's good i'm sorry
special porn ipad like an ipad just for
porn eye porn
yeah i think that's mostly what ipads
are for
porn
i don't i should try don't dudes take
this that to the toilet if they're like
married with kids and [ __ ] yeah what do
you use ipad for mostly i don't have an
ipad do you beat off in the bathroom
with an ipad
no i don't even have an ipad
how do you not have an ipad you have
everything you look like you're asking
has an ipad
are you giving us christmas hands i
don't have one but i would love ultra
i'd rather print out a magazine
print out a magazine so with the
accurate paper style and everything and
the binding yep i go to i pull up the
porno on pornhub and then i print out
that page just like that like a flip
book and then you go on etsy hit up a
small business that makes magazines i
basically seen a lot of old school
playboys at thrift shops now i haven't
seen that
together i love old school playboys
though yeah old school 90s old school's
like yeah family and 80s to early 2000s
that's the golden era plus they got that
like kind of like hazy kind of film on
all of it everything's a little bit more
you know from being matched on yeah
the chicks are bushy in there they're
very busy times yeah yeah sometimes it
takes me out of it you have to just
watch like porn made for women on
pornhub it's this what does that look
like
it's shot well good plot line it's good
it's just two dudes [ __ ] each other
interior design is a bit better is this
real no yeah yeah guys just google
films bless our films yeah ooh he knows
the good stuff yeah
that's like bokeh you're the tuk tuk
patrol
that's stevie weeby's favorite
favorite porn site what's the other one
called yes nacho's adventure yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's what i was
like that was one of those was it nachos
in my pants it was like panchos or
something
this is very interesting
would you guys like to watch them at
this point yeah let's watch it this is
immediately becoming a patreon video
yeah it's a patreon video
the lighting is not this is done for
women by women yes well i don't know if
it's women
this is porn by women oh so we're like
celebrating like women's like no no it's
like women's taste this is what women
want to see so like the gaffer is a
woman the like the electric form well
the storylines are for women look at the
lighting look at look at the lighting oh
wow lighting is good it's very realistic
it probably takes away the girl when
they're like oh my god the interior
design is horrible i can't [ __ ] to this
[ __ ] yeah yeah
they forgot to close the door
a guy could just have a [ __ ] mattress
or like a [ __ ]
or a taxi or a taxi just nothing that's
too dramatic this is that this is taking
things slowly i get it usually i'm
[ __ ] off by now yeah
what is this [ __ ] let's do this skip and
skip forwards yeah no no leave it before
we watch this we're like this is weird
but when we're watching people pound
each other we're like yeah cool yeah
oh
look at the lighting but it's so
dramatic though
that's like that's a very romantic
[ __ ] i can see why this is
appreciated
this is good stuff dude this is like the
brown bunny
you don't even have to censor it because
you covered the whole thing yeah
that's pretty crazy yeah it's not bad
right yeah i could see that yeah i guess
see so this is done by a woman
i don't know
is that missionary you don't see
missionary
they want the guys but i don't want to
see the guys that's weird if this was a
uh what about the what about the climax
let's see let's see he better come here
not all over her [ __ ] hair you know
what i want to see at the end i just
wanted to go morongo
yeah
that looks like the morocco commercial
i'm like what is this
he's going to come on her [ __ ] little
spoiler there what is this wow wow he
has a flexible dick i don't think i
could do that yeah that would hurt me he
bent it all the way down like that like
that you don't like that oh here's the
climax oh
there it is
this is why they didn't even show the
cub shot what you just are he just comes
on his knuckles oh
he just you just screamed on his nose
that's what that's what women are more
into that's what they want that's what
they need yeah kind of dark lighting
right now i actually start lighting some
booty dramatic lighting
i don't like it yeah
no i'm not into that i want to see
close-up of the pal give me browsers or
bang bros any day any day of the week
twice on sunday and 10 times at church
jesus should we pull up a tuk-tuk patrol
just for reference
just for comparison
know